Do you know what this cool thing is?
It is very small, but it can do many different things.
It can be many things.
It can be a computer, a camera, a phone, a movie player, and a music player.
I wonder what some of those buttons are for.
Touch the sunflower button to view photos.
Listen to music with the iTunes button,...
...or touch the button with the envelope to check your e-mail.
It is iPhone.
It is made by a company called Apple.
iPhones came out in stores in 2007.
They are very popular now.
Do you know anyone who has an iPhone?
Have you used one before?
Is it difficult?
Should I take my iPhone swimming?
No way!
iPhones are very fun, but they are not really a toy.
They are expensive, so be very careful when you hold it.
You are also small, and you can do many things.
You are more amazing than an iPhone, so take good care of yourself.